I want to take away fair you know
irrational fears traumatic fears fears
created because you do not handle mental
issues
as grief emotion PTSD
trauma depression
those things we are going to tackle and
somebody's got to do this and I should
have no fear to accomplish that you know
a man on a mission should not think him
in fear you should go and accomplish
this Mission and be focused I think
everybody in the world who suffered a
trauma is deeply impacted we go to the
Moon we go to Mars but we don't know how
to stop out immune diseases cancer
depression anxiety fear for death fear
what is the soul it's still unknown and
I tell you it is the time for the soul
we will show that the purpose of life is
Right within us